Dave Grohl is no longer working with a divorce lawyer
and says he doesn't want to lose his family.
We gotta pull a few lessons from this whole Dave Grohl thing
now that we're seeing it play out all the way.
Number one, they come back.
Your baby daddy. They always come back.
Of course they come back. They didn't necessarily have a baby with you
because they wanted to love and grow their family.
They wanted to forever link themselves to you
so that they always have a foot in the door.
Hey, how's my kid?
Okay,
so if you're worried if he's gonna come back,
he's probably gonna come back.
And, no,
you should not take him back.
I don't think Dave Grohl's wife should take him back.
Absolutely not. No.
Because here's the thing. Once you've seen that level of cruelty,
it doesn't matter how many apologies this person gives you,
you can't ever unsee it. Like when someone shows you a picture,
those fucking optical illusions,
and you're like, is it a vase
or is it two faces kissing?
Well, you can always see both sides now.
You're always gonna be able to see it for both sides.
So is the tarnish is there.
No matter how sweet and wholesome,
hmm, and talented and kind and genuine the guy may seem,
he is still capable of being the kind of piece of shit
that will go and cheat on you
after 20 something years of dedication.
And knock another woman up
and then lawyer up, like,
protect himself before he's about to hurt you. Motherfucker.
You hurt me in the cheating.
You hurt me and having the baby.
You're hurting me in the divorce,
and you're the one protecting yourself.
Like I have any power to do anything to you.
Like he is a cold, calculated piece of shit.
So, you know,
just look at these stories and take the lessons
and apply them into your own life.
Never think you're so fucking unique,
it could never happen to you.
If it could happen to her,
it could happen to you. If it could happen to me, it could happen to you.